afraid to go in  exploration always carries risk  I say we risk it  take us in hi sir  the toast union service is just as much  about mundane busy work as it is about  Adventure where are we going  what the hell good morning Commander  good morning Lieutenant you're an  interesting species you know how to fly  one of these things we're about to find  out  I Now command the full might of krill  let's wipe them off the face of the  Galaxy  you could feel joy happiness affection  Love I can have your heart for your soul  show the Galaxy that humans are  different that we value life even when  our enemies don't  [Applause]  thank you  just hit the button before you hit the  ground good luck  if you do the right thing in the Here  and Now  future has a way of taking care of  yourself  [Music]  enough